[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not
Gonna Let Me In hey hey
baptism gang let me see you gunk
welcome back to the break room Our Daily
Show like keep you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know about coming
up today we're just going to talk about
black panthers
what else is there to talk about unless
it's your birthday then happy birthday
but let me also introduce Our Guest
Erica hey everybody hey internet how
y'all doing happy black panther day and
it is a friend's birthday our friend
Khalil shout out to you
you're welcome
um speaking of black kings
welcome Tommy back told yes yes I'm uh
I'm A Team all right I don't normally
identify as a black king but I'll take
it for today that sounds great I could
also be your red bearded King I can be
your king-sized Snickers bar I can be
whatever you want king size what
Snickers
oh my God what did you say the Snickers
come back
[Laughter]
no no just quit saying it
so there's the day that me and Eric are
allowed Three Musketeers
Three Musketeers we broke Tommy two
minutes
I need a Monday motivation oh no well
we'll get into it uh but also I didn't
finish my white king
I'm a bishop oh the most phallic of all
the chess pieces it's our Monday
motivation for our Redemption today
every time we hit a hundred dollars in
super chats we're going to spin our
motivate we're not going to spin a wheel
We're Not Gonna spin bucket we got a
bucket here full of great inspirational
things uh which uh we'll do for it's not
we'll come to Forever motivation we'll
give you an example we'll give you a
little taste
oh okay you're really good at it hey
everybody
it's Monday and uh new trailer may have
dropped in your life and when there's
new trailers that means you got to do
breakdowns so here's a little motivation
to Eric Voss oh yeah he's watching hey
Pretty Ricky oh it's your boy TV stunner
oh I know that the Black Panther what
kind of forever trailer just dropped and
you're probably overwhelmed because
you've been spending all weekend
thinking about your Jacksonville Jaguars
blowing a lead to the Philadelphia
Eagles
no need to fret because the Buffalo
Bills got this league in control anyway
now sharing first place statistically
not tiebreaker with the Miami Dolphins
in the AMC East you need you need you
need to get to click clacking on that
keyboard son because we gotta have that
breakdown out we need those sweet sweet
likes we need those ad dollars so we can
keep making the break room which does
almost as good a numbers as the
breakdowns in Easter egg videos almost
as good but boss I need to work it in
overdrive I need your G fueling I need
you athletic greens I need you all of
our sponsors get in the a coffee called
juice up wakanda forever hey
the Seahawks won
um the Seahawks beat the Detroit Lions
which is kind of like beating I don't
know like an infant at soccer we're not
beating it coming for me like that
he's more coming from the Detroit Lions
I think with that one okay okay okay I
don't know what do you think about
football I don't know anything about
football but you know what I do know
what do you know what do you know I know
about these headlines
uh so we'll be talking all about Black
Panther wakanda forever today you guys
as I said at the beginning uh tomorrow
we'll be talking more about all the
other news even stuff that happened over
the weekend that doesn't include wakanda
forever and today like Waldron writing
for secret rewards we are just focusing
on wakanda forever today as you see from
our black panther mask so we got them
yeah ladies and gentlemen we got them
uh I beg for you guys to let me wear the
mask but everybody said no even though
you're just
[Laughter]
so besides just a trailer for Black
Panther wakanda we also got several new
posters and images uh let's run through
those really quickly I can't really see
the screen though come on the internet
cam let's see some okay we've got this
wait do we not have the assets
perfect timing for the segment this
Show's going to hell
yeah the way we started this show and
just what we're doing now we've got the
standard poster to the
okay I Can't Describe these they're two
I mean they put out a bunch of posters
they did There's characters from the
movies there's logos you guys have seen
them IMAX one is really intense it's
like it's just is it the the headdress
that tanak has it was like a really big
oh God you guys need to look at it we'll
get those up soon but yeah there's like
the real 3D the 4dx the Dolby the IMAX
the standard one there's the people the
people who live in in dumpsters that
watch our show the the ones they crumple
up and throw in the trash you know the
free ones you get you guys will see a
lot of those coming into your houses
soon this is the poster for people who
go to sporting events and they take
pictures of it even though they're like
500 feet from the stage and their flash
is on your flash is not doing anything
no they made a poster for you yeah yeah
you wanna talk about the main people in
most of the posters we could also just
come back to it once the board is
working because I feel weird kind of
like trying to describe it from memory
because I might have got some people
wrong uh but a lot of the posters do
feature shuri like front and center oh
okay and we'll get in there a whole
discussion today but this is like there
it looks like they're really pushing her
forward in this movie yeah they're
giving her a shot they're giving her
they're giving her the title for a
little bit it sounds like I still think
she's sure the red herring but oh yeah I
think she will all the posters I've
heard like dead center and the floating
head posters and I know you guys in the
chat hate it when I say this I'm tired
of those floating head posters
well we were kind of joking about like
the IMAX poster it's really cool but the
side just has kind of like smoke and
it's like well let's put something else
there maybe there's a magician oh or
maybe there's a haunted house element of
the of the movie like waves put some
waves
because as I just looked up on Google oh
one of the things that helped flood
wakanda was the whole battle between the
X-Men and the Avengers name or in
retaliation for Scarlet Witch almost
killing him in the battle added lenses
uh floods wakanda so Navy
there'll be ramifications
from the comic but yes
I like that
um just scroll we'll come back we'll
come back we'll come back to these
photos
we have a lot of headlines about what
Carnival I'm just kidding we have a ton
so I'll get into the ew yeah so ew send
out a new has a new article today that
is flooded with so much behind the
scenes details for wakanda forever and
she's talking to Ryan coogler about it
they speak on Namor not being the
selfish villain that we've all seen in
the comics
says maybe the most important choice in
the character is that he's not a selfish
person here just goes on to say he's
taking care of a community he's not
individualist he's part of a try do we
do we think that this means that like I
like the idea of like he's not a selfish
person we don't think he's the villain
well this is also the actor who portrays
him right I think he sees him in a
different light yes and he sees his
motivations as being honest and true and
important to his people now at the
expense of everyone else I don't know
you know what Coral does them and have
with a boot you might ask to him he
doesn't care what happens on the surface
world right as long as they quit dumping
their plastic in the ocean yeah you're
killing them or turn it into an island
we can all float on right right they're
saying that your mic's not on my mind
yeah
um how about now
um
hi is Eric's Mike okay
sorry I believe everyone in the chat
because I trust you guys so much
um yeah I don't it's so interesting to
see all the new pieces to Neymar because
I'm like yeah you might not be bad but a
lot of this uh what we're seeing doesn't
make you look good right I mean you know
the comics is like a long history of
struggle between him and what kind of
they don't trust each other they're
always they're on like almost like a
nuclear arms race most of the time about
like who's gonna destroy who what are
they up to they got spies on the inside
they also have like diplomats that go
but they also will recall them when they
want to attack and stuff like Neymar
like you said a flight of wakanda he
also did a thing where he told uh he
told Thanos or may he implied that like
one of the Infinity Stones was in
wakanda knowing Thanos would go there to
destroy one concert to get it and he
later reveals that to uh to Jolla where
he's like I did that uh because I was
mad at you guys oh yeah yeah so yeah so
for tonight to be like yeah he's just a
guy he's part of a tribe and he's trying
to protect them so he's not well yeah to
him he's not a villain but interesting
we might see his actions as villainous I
don't know but I do think that there is
something else to this film I heard that
he's testing is the highest villain ever
for a Marvel movie get out of here he's
gonna beat Gore in the test I just
assume every Marvel movie they say that
about everything villain is actually
testing the highest it's ever tested
they absolutely do that well above grade
um the Black Panther will kind of
forever production designer Hannah
beechler used inspiration from classic
Spielberg movies which I think is really
fun be sure is cryptic about the exact
details this is a Marvel movie so you
know they're never going to give you the
full answer but she does tease level
Khan forever takes visual inspiration
from Steven Spielberg's jaws and Close
Encounters of the Third Kind as well as
the classic Jack Kirby comic imagery I'm
sorry win in the trailer we're talking
about the trailer now right yeah yeah
when he drops down into that giant shark
jaw as the throne that was awesome I
want that for my house if you want to
sit at a giant shark jaw do you think
that's just the only Jaws
kind of reminiscent of the Jaws poster
yeah oh yeah it's like a lady at the top
oh yeah but there's also like we see
them this was in both trailers kind of
them like grabbing onto it looks like a
humpback whale or something to like ride
along and the shots from underneath it
where you're like from The View
underneath that's like very Jaws I'm
sure there's going to be lots of jump
scares the sun glistening going through
the water kind of blinding you yeah
what's the Close Encounters of the Third
Kind well a father abandons his family
that's most of the the Spielberg movies
but also just the idea of like these
people or these you know to us they're
alien you know they might as well be
aliens from outer space they're coming
from the deep dark ocean something we've
explored less than our own space right
uh I think just that idea like how do we
communicate with them what are their
intentions maybe we fear them at first
but it turns out no they're here to help
us like that kind of stuff just like uh
embracing the unknown and how do you
interact with something you've never
interacted with before with fire and
brimstone right right kill the fire kill
it kill it then you ask questions yeah
yeah
also close encounters a lot about like
communication like I wouldn't expect
that the telokins or toe oceans or
however whatever they're called speak
English you know what I mean like is
their their own language they have to
communicate their water you know how how
much of it they see it these you see
them going down into that throne room
and that room is filled with water but
is there a part of the underwater
Kingdom that is not filled with water
because like Ant-Man or not Ant-Man the
Aquaman thing where they have like the
weird like right step out of it and then
the water just falls off yeah yeah yeah
or like because in the comics part of
Atlantis was domed at one point and then
they evolved to like breathe water but I
don't know if there's like a domed area
in this I don't know but I like dolphins
where they can like be out and out of
the water for a little bit and then
they're like and then you gotta go back
in the water they'll dry out you gotta
keep them wet we all saw Free Willy I
didn't because I wasn't born
you guys haven't seen the Free Willy
movies they're great he jumps over a
wall oh yeah
I'd say who jumps over the wall
someone jumps a wall uh so there is
another part in the uh in the ew article
that says reread's relationship with
Sherry will mirror t'challa's
relationship with killmonger just as the
original black panther accommodated the
diversity of the black experience
contrasting the African t'challa with
the American killmonger Michael B Jordan
wakanda forever will explore similar
territory with shuri in the chicago-born
Riri Wright says she's particularly
excited for young black girls to fall in
love with another role model like Riri
just as they fell in love with shuri I
think that's so interesting because does
that mean they're going to be enemies at
first or does that mean is the contrast
more on their like culturally like she's
coming from Chicago she's not coming
from the Bay Area she's coming from
Chicago and this is after the whole like
killmonger situation so this is like and
then they say that she's like an MIT
student uh in the movie are we going
with that I believe they said that she's
involved with MIT and I think that's
what we know from Iron Heart too I know
from the comics but I was like I don't
know if they're gonna do that well we
did see a d23 the little bit of
ironheart footage they showed they
brought back Jim Rash yeah from the
actor from Community who was also in
Iron Man 3 when he gives the scholarship
at MIT in general or not that was Iron
Man 3 that was Civil War I apologize uh
and Jim Rash is like what about my
programs you know what I mean that guy
comes back so we know riri's going to
MIT at some point we don't know in the
timeline where this fits this is pre-mit
I'm so it's interesting and I'm I just I
guess I'm curious as like it can't well
it can be a cultural situation where
it's like you're in wakanda and I'm
Chicago but that was the first movie and
now the Chicago wakanda has now opened
the gates to everyone and was like Hey
we're gonna start opening stations for
them to learn and like get really into
stem I'm like is it still going to be
the same situation maybe it doesn't
reach everybody it only reached as far
as the West Coast well that like they
said they were going to open up and then
a lot of other stuff happened right yeah
and all that so it's like that maybe
never came to fruition also I could see
Riri being you know like interacting
with Sherry and being like this is great
and all but like I you know I don't have
all these resources like I had to do
this on my own like you were born into
royalty in a very rich country that was
separated from the rest of the world
yeah 100 like don't tell me how to do my
science lady get out of here understands
my way that's also true I I like that
idea of being like my science is still
good right it's vibranium like I don't
have yeah I don't have that it's like
yeah of course you're inventing all this
amazing stuff I gotta take apart like an
old Toyota Corolla and like turn it into
something I don't imagine my job shuri
don't tell me I do my job I like that
and them coming together uh towards the
end of just being not even towards the
end probably like in the beginning well
into it they'll probably get together
and be like this is fine yeah we come
from two different technological
standpoints yeah it looks like they're
both you know working in the lab where
they did the you know handshake thing
that shuri and tashallah did in the
trailer so I mean even just in working
in the lab together they just you know
hey how's your weekend you know and then
eventually get to you know me being born
in Chicago having a scrape for
everything I had are you hungry because
I'm hungry you want to get lunch you're
right it's I I have ideological
conversations the way it's a challenge
um yeah I want to see what uh Ryan
coogler says is the like justification
for it because I am not a stem person I
don't know anything but I would love to
see how it's like we can still use
technology technology that's not what
Condon technology to actually help
Advance techno uh wakanda technology so
I'm hoping he has something like that
where it's like rereads like I have the
ax like it's a Honda Accord like a
normal thing that can actually bring
more information uh so Dominic Thorne
who plays Riri Williams originally
auditioned for the black the first Black
Panther movie She auditioned which
immediately was I was like who the hell
is she audition for sure it has to be
sure yeah it could be like sure yeah but
she would have been so young though or
what if it was a dorm a lot yeah okay so
she was okay so or there could have been
like
some stuff said in the past like with a
younger child a young shirt or something
like that yeah so it's uh and to answer
that first one uh so Thorne actually
auditioned for the original black
panther back when she was a sophomore in
college she didn't get the role sometime
further on she received a call from
Marvel producer Moore who asked her if
she was familiar with Ruby Williams when
Thorne said yes
she assumed Moore would ask her to
audition or send in a self tape instead
he offered her the role right then and
there wow also if Marvel ever calls you
and asks if you're familiar with the
character yes 100 certainty you say then
you get that marble a little bit of
subscription that night
I'm just scrolling through it Ruby
Williams nowhere very well yeah I can
play name more yeah I can swim no yeah
well he lied about that right yeah he
said I've never drowned yeah
she is like four years younger than me
because I genuinely was like I was out
of college for two years and then I was
like oh this makes sense with a role
like sure there's a chance that they
were going for like an age range of
young girl right like they're like she
could be as young as like yeah early
teens in his own this you know whatever
um and then lastly Ryan coogler
considered quitting filmmaking after the
death of Chadwick Boseman he said I was
at a point when I was like I'm walking
away from the business coogler 36
right now 36.
did you just do like the Kevin Hart when
yeah
admits I didn't know if I could make
another movie period another Black
Panther movie because it hurt a lot I
was like man how could I open myself up
to feeling like this again yeah I mean I
don't debt it you know this is a great
article the Entertainment Weekly one and
he's very like honest in it and it's it
is you know because he made the first
movie he planted all these seeds and
then like you know he had no idea about
Chadwick's illness most people did not
and it was like a total shock and he had
to like start all over again which is
kind of crazy I I have a question that's
slightly related to this but not not the
sad parts of this this wasn't
Entertainment Weekly going out of
business were they gonna oh that's why
they're ew now well they don't do them
they don't do the physical things oh
this is all digital yeah man this is a
huge gift for them because normally like
an article like that where you're like
oh the director or the actor were really
forthcoming is like in Vanity Fair yeah
like variety for like a a center like a
a cover piece they do like digital
covers now oh that's just some cool
emotion
194 please and seven people shared that
number there was Jimmy Ferguson Joe
petranto Mary Beth story James Burns
Kevin O'Leary the shark this is the
million the billionaire they're still
wonderful Nancy mazichetti and Senior
Jose
who'd insisted on being referred to as
that I'll let you have that one time
because you're so old but senior Jose
Ramirez sounds inappropriate that's just
how he introduced himself
there was also Madame Willa Divine and
she'd let you peek under her trousers
for a nickel
and we did and we did somewhere that's
right back
under trousers isn't that erotic you
just look under the one pant leg you see
a sock or a bare ankle and if it was a
bare ankle that pole better be yes by a
hundred percent cancel me and I'll leave
right now
John has uh been able to bring back our
images so let's get a quick Glimpse at
these images and what we've got so
um
sorry
um Okay so we've got the standard poster
in the middle uh real D 3D on the top
left the 40x on the top right me and
John have seen a lot of 40x movies we
love seeing it IMAX in the bottom left
on the bottom right uh we need more
weird theater format so we can get more
posters I mean we were joking like if
you go see this movie in for the action
gets sprayed with water so much
me and John Wayne saw the hitman's
bodyguard's wife
well that one demanded
was fun and then afterwards we're like
we were like so mad it was horrible also
this is gonna be two hours and 41
minutes of Atlantis water and spraying
on you so a real nail biter in the
cancel Time
wow it appears as though I'm starting to
radicalize some of the chat
let's make the chat great again uh easy
they gonna storm new rock stars this
January 6th we're all getting together
Vancouver we were like oh we're gonna
talk about only black panther wakanda
forever get the most Problems
by the way IMAX if you're listening we
need another poster to go with our whole
universe of Madness poster give us one
of those black panther posters baby
please and thank you put it right up
there right up on our poster we'll put
it up on the wall of fame where the
she-hawk fantasy winner will go
um so we got also a bunch of new images
first up the Okoye and Ramana image
here they're so pretty look at them side
profiles oh they're gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous girls gorgeous gorgeous girls
gorgeous gorgeous girls star in wakanda
Forever feel the gap of the loss of a
leader of a Nation gorgeous gorgeous
girl let me tell you about it that's a
queen and a queen so then we got Okoye
and shuri what is happening in this
picture the thing is it's not what is
happening in this picture it's uh you
know what's happening well they're about
to clear me drop a rap out U.S somewhere
or maybe wherever like the U.N why can
you bring the image one more time why
are you sure you're wearing a 90s
friends dressed in like a rejected out
there from a Wesley whoa we don't know
we don't know what what kind of fashion
is that right now they could be at the
height of fact they're not they're not
Baron Zemo what are you talking about I
wish parents email would wear that as a
flag Blazer also I like the image it
looks like they're trying to be in
hiding and they're not hiding blend in
with this purple shirt it's 10 sizes too
big but it's clearly adorable
like sit in there mad
um John offered maybe they're on their
way to pick up Riri from MIT oh and the
only way to pull up at MIT is in
sunglasses and a nice nice 90s jacket uh
we also get this glorious shot of Angela
Bassett hanging out on the beach
we're gonna switch seats for this
segment so you can see yeah we should
switch and in the trailer I want to sit
next to Brandon we saw like uh Neymar
confronting Ramada on the beach all up
in her Grill this Beach area yeah and
like the shot we have anybody see this
so hot yeah this is my ass is on fire
it's because my ass is fire okay
hmm I kind of like it
um uh and there was a shot last week too
that came out of like shuri and raimondo
with like Spears and also like they were
on maybe a beachy area where is this
beach also because we know
we have that I don't know where this
beach is that's a good question it did
seem there was are you talking about the
one where we saw umbaku uh jump off the
ship at
he looks so huge in that trailer Winston
Duke is that yeah built marry me Winston
oh my God so this is the picture of
embaku in his new suit this man so fine
went to Brighton High School won't claim
his Rochester Heritage though says he's
from from New York City which I can't if
I was from New York I'd claim New York
City too why won't you just admit you
went to Brighton High School Winston
come on the break room let's talk
Section 5 sports and finally we
brightened up this photo but you know
what it is who's in the suit
I'm I'm dead serious believing in Sherry
just because of every floating head we
have her dead front and center yeah
what's your theory
or do you want to get into another
discussion well we could talk about it
right now we will be doing a mandatory
fun as well okay so let's go let's go
inside I do think that like they want us
to assume that that is sure between the
first shot of the trailer or very early
on the trailer is shuri's face with the
white dots at what we assume is like the
funeral or
life celebration whatever you're going
to call it of t'challa and then very
similar kind of dots on on the Black
Panther outfit right I feel like that
they want to do that what they did not
give us in this trailer is like face
nanotech yes it comes on right so it's
like they're purposely not doing that uh
and I kind of agree with Eric that like
both I don't know if you Eric Fosters
here I don't know if you have this
Theory Erica was so but like there could
be multiple blocks yeah I could see that
I could see that easily because why pick
one yeah I can see that but it also
comes down to does anyone get the
heart-shaped herb right because that's
part of it too uh producer John and I
were kind of going on about this is like
how much power does the suit give you uh
because whoever's in that suit they fell
from a height yeah they hit the ground
you can see the purple kinetic energy
being absorbed or whatever so that's
absorbing some of the fog but still like
you're like my knees man I can't jump
off uh I can't skip a step on a uh
walking down the stairs or else up a lot
of knee I'm only 20 though you're gonna
end up like Bill Walton just unable to
jump even an inch off the air Sports
reference guys sorry about that
SpongeBob first of all these guys were
all born in the 2000s Bill Walton
retired is it well known that Bill
Walton can't jump yeah he almost like he
he couldn't move at all because his feet
and his knees were so bad he was okay do
you ever read his biography Bill Walton
uh said he didn't even want to live
anymore because his knees and feet hurt
so bad you know I did hear a rumor that
he is the uh inspiration for the movie
White Men Can't Jump yeah
all day if you've got questions about
this trailer there uh this trailer there
go ahead and uh at new rockstars in the
chat send us your questions we'll try
and get to some of yours too you guys
have been sending your super chats we
could use more Super chats if you feel
like it we are doing some Monday
motivations Monday motivation we have
gotten some super chats already though
Bucky Barnes ATL saying let's keep it
Gucci to moochie baby happy Monday let's
go what kind of food chat redemptions
aren't off we got Monday motivation yeah
that's right uh Brian Pellerin saying
shout out to the den of nerds crazy MCU
news hype video I don't know what that
is I don't know what that is are you
promoting someone else on our Channel
yeah what do you work for them what do
you work for reveal yourself Canadian
currency what is that a loon that's two
that's a toonie and three quarters they
don't even have pennies in Canada
anymore they they got rid of the pennies
yeah they pay for everything in Maple
Leaves uh and then like uh
we're in Vancouver big black gaming
setting in a super chat I don't know if
it's true I have not verified whether
this is true or not if it's not go after
big black gaming in the chat but bottom
right frame at 129 of the trailer shows
a black panther suit with no dots on the
helmet are we getting multiple black
panther suits in this movie maybe
possibly quick Theory possibly one black
panther suit is almost like a Batman
Beyond situation okay suit gives power
but the person makes the suit with their
bravery and whatnot so it could be so
what I think happens is kind of like at
the uh towards the that last battle with
Thanos in endgame where they were
playing keep away with The Infinity
Gauntlet I feel like Okoye shuri and
um Lupita nyongo's character I can't
remember her name right now Nikia I'm
going to toss the little black panther
necklace a monkey okay you be the
panther now action action action give me
this hand then out and that's what's
gonna happen that's fun that's kind of
like um the Seahawks quote is that uh
we're the 12th man you know what I'm
saying like we're all no I don't know
all the people at this table that you
turn to for supporters
Brandon was like why are you wearing a
sports Jersey that's terrible that's my
uh Bill Walton impression
there were multiple wrestlers have
portrayed Kane over the years
you put on the red one a lot of people
played the uh the blue blazers the blue
yeah yeah Doink the Clown was playing
multiple people now I'm awesome well
even in the first movie the whole final
battle we get is because there are two
black panther suits so we know that they
make multiple Seasons I've told several
actors have played Batman over the years
you know why Sherry's probably also
there helping it's like you need more
hands on deck to make more suits or a
suit that's so capable
sorry riri's there so there you can make
it more capable for everyone to get one
suit or just to make multiple different
versions I wanted a better shot of that
Iron Heart suit though man how already
happened to that because like what I
missed the old iron I like the new Iron
Man suits are great they're Sleek
they're nanotech but when you go back
and watch those old ones and you hear
that thing work and click and the fire
that comes out is visceral and like I
like that I don't need all the glowing
repulsory stuff I want some fire I want
some engines yeah I want a V8 you you
got House of the Dragon
oh my gosh the car is up in this uh well
as we talk about the suits what about
the heart-shaped herb right because
that's a big component of this we saw
killmonger say burn it all and they
burned it obviously one was saved to get
d'challa his powers back and also we
were speculating like killmonger doesn't
know where all the hard-shaped areas if
that guy's there he's taking over he's
taking he's like burn all this and
you're a priest you're like yeah you
gotta see it we burned it yeah good
going they could have saved some seeds
I've talked about it before the roots
could grow back yeah they're just
harvesting The Roots yeah I do I really
believe that shury's gonna make some
sort of synthetic yeah synthetic a
different version of it that still was
capable of doing it maybe one bucket
when they had Bucky there for a few
years on Ice they were like let's take
some of his blood and figure out the
super soldier serum
yeah yeah that's like the new energy
drink in wakanda is white wolf
black panther suits around here with
Brad panko's in Japan and shoot some
weird commercials for stuff like they
got Bucky Barnes in wakanda like
promoting like white werewolf energy
drink that's hilarious because in the
real world Nigeria is moving to ban
white actors from being in commercials
because too many like white and foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
another thing I wanted to talk to you
guys about is kind of the similarities
between Neymar and t'challa it's crying
and wakanda in like to lotion right
to Logan
in this trailer we see a lot of
interesting kind of cuts between
characters especially when things are
being said and you can kind of take that
as like an artistic comparison right the
chair the trailer will cut between like
wakanda and Neymar in the opening kind
of saying that they have like the same
story there's a lot of those match cuts
um and then we see umbaku talk about
like they refer to uh Namor as uh the
serpent the feather serpent God right
he's the protector of this like hidden
Society king or a general no this like
hidden land very similar to like
t'challa right uh and they're both sort
of like avatars for a God uh t'challa
being the avatar for Boss uh and then uh
uh Neymar being the avatar are for I
cannot say the name of that guy I forgot
Catan or something like that apologies
to colloquatan okay uh and they're
they're guarding these secret societies
and they were both bred for a position
of royalty like they knew his children
like hi you're gonna be leading these uh
people your people your tribes right
that's something that's very different
from a lot of Marvel uh Heroes uh you
know Tony Stark wasn't born knowing he
was gonna be Iron Man he was born no
he's knowing he's gonna be a rich
[ __ ] but like that you know Peter
Parker wasn't born no he's gonna do this
that's a big thing in Marvel is like
having the responsibility put on your
shoulders and what you do with that
choice yes these these men have to make
choices in their life but like they knew
that they were always going to be
leaders of their people so that's very
interesting and I I think that leads to
like to not quit to saying like I don't
see him as a villain right he's just
doing what's best for his people and we
don't treat the oceans well so I see why
he's pissed it's not what every person
who plays a villain in a Marvel movie
says though yeah I think that he's
actually got like in from his point of
view he's doing the right thing by
eradicating the only one that said it
was Drake Drake up was the only one he
was always like my weirdos desire to be
women with no mind that actor was like
no my character is a piece of [ __ ] yeah
that is my character I love villains let
me tell you where are we know
it is truly that the killmongers
in my opinion
uh I'm gonna steal this one right now
because I already see it uh Freight girl
asking will we see the astral plane and
the connection between t'challa and
Neymar I don't see it's it's tough right
[Music]
I'm really torn on this because I'm like
uh if you saw Ghostbusters afterlife uh
and if you didn't spoiler alert but go
see if you're gonna see it if you
haven't seen this point but I don't care
I haven't go see it they do it they have
a digital Harold Ramis in that film uh
and I think what they do is beautiful
they don't try and do a voice which I
think is very good very good call but he
is there and you know this movie was
made by him that movie was made by his
son and I think it was a decision that
was made that's fine if you show the
ancestral plane I mean you could show a
literal Panther we know they take that
form but a digital yeah I don't know I
don't think Ryan I don't think he would
either do it but I would like an idea
that like this Panther does represent
him yeah like that would be a great oh
here comes John it tells us no but you
also have what they did with um Corey
Fisher for the latest yeah movie which
is they have all this footage that they
might not have used right I'm losing my
voice
um don't cry it's okay in that first
film that they could they could
repurpose it somewhere else
thanks John back to you uh but if if
anyone does take the heart-shaped over
in this movie I expect to see them in
the ancestral plane yeah and like I
could almost see Romanza being like I
want to take the herb to see my stomach
and my husband and my husband
he probably he's probably sick of his
[ __ ] he still loves her son right yeah
she's probably like you know you married
a long time
I'll check them next time next time
uh but I mean that that will I will be
crushed emotionally in the theater if
they have something like that
yeah yeah yeah I just want to mention
before we move on our Monday motivations
I don't know if we've explained well
enough they are black panther trailer
themes they are most stations for people
going through it in the Black Panther
trailer so everything is Black Panther
theme today uh uh take it from your
black king all right they're all black
panthers I can't say it I guess you
can't you can say okay I'm surrounded by
people they can say it I've just been
Hang on we're getting a report I'm being
told I can't say that uh I want to
rescind that I'm just a king you put any
color on me you want except from Orange
that ain't my color uh Jan Mitchell on
the chat saying I got my mandatory fun
mug yes
um Ruby Williams has also been described
as a foil in this film to shuri uh this
was in that Entertainment Weekly article
Kugler and sad quote the film deals with
a lot of things but one of them is foils
uh people who exist in contrast but
there's a threat of similarity in this
film we get to see Sherry meet someone
who has some things in common with her
but is also very different so you got we
were kind of talking about this earlier
but do you think uh the differences
between shuri and Riri will play out in
like any significant way or is this
going to be something that like uh they
push each other to be better you know
that the idea of like iron sharpens iron
right like I'm smart you're smart let's
be smart together let's put our
differences aside because I could see
where Riri Williams might be annoyed
much like killmonger was like where were
you guys aren't you helping people
around the world like we're out here
struggling like you know she's we don't
know her situation in Chicago but it
might not be great you know she could be
seeing a lot of violence there so it's
like why aren't you guys helping it's
not fair do you think that she's just
gonna come off as a more understanding
version of come on I I don't like saying
it like that but like again her
intentions are not evil but like she
might be just have a chip on her
shoulder about it plus you know they're
comparing her to Tony Stark Goliath and
Iron Man obviously Iron Heart Iron Man
all that she builds a suit uh he was a
very opinionated selfish braggadocious
type dude someone who's very smart and
has probably been the smartest person in
the room wherever she goes like bristle
and someone telling her what to do well
I think it'll be kind of like how in
Black Panther one remember when shuri
was showing like the new gear like the
boot and the new kind of nanotech black
panther suit that could just form on you
uh I think it'll be like that I think
they'll you know rib each other and like
give each other a little grief kind of
how like t'challa and shuri gave each
other like sibling you know they were
smart asses to each other I think that's
what foil means in this and so there
will be a little bit of I'm a black
American I'm a black wakandan type of
you know
playfulness yeah yeah but I don't think
it'll be a killmonger level but I don't
know because you know it sure is or has
invited Riri to come work in the
wakandan lab and build her own stuff in
a wakandan lab so I don't think that'll
be like enemies or anything like that
but just kind of like playful familial
type oils to each other yeah I I know
riri's going to want to get her hand on
some vibranium though oh yeah that'll be
interesting to see if that carries over
into an Ironhide series at all do you
think she's building her suit not
entirely of vibranium but working in a
wakandan lab I don't this is something
we kind of talked about before because
at d23 the footage they showed from
ironheart seemed she had a very DIY kind
of suit uh there's been some
um art for this movie that came out that
I think was tied to maybe one of those
mobile games that showed Ruby Williams
in kind of like a very homemade looking
suit big bulky very mark one energy yeah
but then you know there's been other
links where you see the Sleek red suit
and that's kind of what we saw on this
trailer right from the bottom it looks
red it looks like it's got very smooth
lines like it looks like a very
well-built suit uh I would hope she gets
her hand on some vibrating for it it
would be mean to be like hey you gotta
fight with us yeah we got copper steel
all right that'd be messed up they're
like you can go look in the okay
uh some of our comments from the chat
here uh what's the vibe people are
asking us what's a Vibe do you think
Queen raimonda is gonna die in this
movie I mean can they are they gonna
kill anyone else from Sir Charles
I don't think that would be heavy it
would be great if they just didn't kill
anyone that would be nice we just enter
the phase uh five off of this is the
last movie we just enter it and then
maybe they die in Phase five but like
right now they don't die but if it was
anyone you know one problem will think
of the Angel bastard yeah yeah I think
they are they I mean because some some
parental matriarchal patriarchal figure
always dies Brian coogler would be like
everybody in their family everybody in
that family just passed I mean
I'm just very sad
um
yeah I don't think they're gonna I I
would hate to don't because well you're
not you're not as cool like connected
the only other person would have to be
uh uh um no not about because I don't
think we have that much of an emotional
attachment to Embark right and I don't
think we have the same emotional
attachment to much of the Dora milage
yet and so uh yeah Nikia would be the
only one but I like the theory that she
might be pregnant uh keep going who's
pregnant Angela Nikia oh okay uh what's
the challenge baby I like the idea I've
been reading a lot about it
I also like the idea too that like the
the Black Panther does not have to be
the ruler of wakanda yeah they could be
totally separated things uh and I think
leaving Queen raimonda in as the
figurehead and having uh someone else
carry the Black Panther mantle would be
great uh and very impactful I I would
like uh Jessica we have a hundred
dollars I would like you to do a
motivational speech if you don't mind I
think it's our time yeah each one of
these is themed after the trailer you'll
be able to hopefully tell
what is that one
motivate someone who just got a big
commercial yes this is in honor of
whoever the New Black Panther is yeah
look here
I know it's hard taking that mantle it's
it's hard uh if you've been watching
House of the Dragon no one really wants
to take that mantle but serious it's
crazy I don't mean to turn this into it
attack I was talking dragons but I
understand it's hard there's gonna be a
lot of things coming your way and you're
not prepared for it but that's the best
part about being the Black Panther you
have so much support behind you you have
so much family and you have all of
wakanda which is a nation of a million
people so you are gonna do it you're
gonna be fine you're gonna step out
there in that slick suit looking nice
looking looking like a Mississippi pimp
and you're gonna be like wow I am the
star of this show and you're gonna do
great you're gonna slice through people
with those claws you're gonna do
backflips and you might even get some
new things more vibranium more
heart-shaped herbs and they'll probably
be more of you so I know it's hard and
it looks like we're putting a lot on you
and we are we are very excited for this
but you'll do it and you'll come out
stronger than ever because you're a
black panther I want a t-shirt that says
looking slicker than a Mississippi
and I'm always like it sticks in my head
and I think of barenzyma every time I
think of it it's good also Rio Williams
should help out Sherry and they should
put a jet pack on the back of that black
panther
suits why they leap and jump can they
Glide no they're Panthers they're not
flying they can't do whatever they want
I'm told they can teleport
um we we got more of your questions and
your thoughts that we're going to get to
here in a second but I think we should
yeah we gotta think zombie fueled up we
got to thank some of our sponsors well
our our sponsor G fuel for sponsoring
I'm using the new portal juice Rick and
Morty cup unstable portal unstable
portal that's what I meant
um it's unstable oh it's so good it's
like lemonade on a hot summer day if
you're like you're like me you're a
weekend warrior I spent all weekend this
weekend I spent the whole weekend
I came to the truck there for a second
but all weekend this weekend
playing the ponies and watching 12
straight hours of NFL football needless
to say money disappeared from my wallet
faster than the McFly family from that
photo a reference to Back to the Future
I got 12 hours of football game one bet
after another losing losing ponies
running scampering my personal horse
that I own ladies did every horse make
it to the end most horses were executed
on Santa Anita come on Santa Anita they
still got that luck don't they needless
to say I ain't gonna be able to watch on
Monday without a little Fuel and I'm
talking G fuel baby what is this
unstable portal juice speaking of
unstable you should see me at home who
knows a little G fuel you trash bags
might be able to get out of the
dumpsters and upgrade yourself to a dank
Alleyway with awning coverage you know
what I'm saying maybe a little bit
coverage from the rain down in your
trash juice in fuel G fuel does it and
they don't phone it in with their
flavors all right check out the Rick and
Morty theme flavors I've already said
unstable portal fluid which you can get
as a tub in a collector's box with a
shaker cup also has some fun Halloween
themed flavors for you spooky fuelers
and packs including the Hocus Focus
starter kit and a candy corn pumpkin
Bumble bundle bumble bumble shiver me
timbers this bubble is the app I'm on
swiping right like crazy doesn't matter
what you look like the Beck man is
desperate click the link in the
description and use code new rockstars
to get 30 off your order this is what's
important care before look at me right
now
you got to use the code this is a
pay-to-play scenario guys you want to
save a few bucks you got to use our code
g fuel ain't giving us that money unless
you use our code so new rockstars you
get 30 off guys that means you're only
paying 70 I'm not a math wizard but
that's less than 100 use the code it not
only saves you some cash it helps us
create and create more of this sweet
sweet content you want to see Talking
dragons you want to see the break room
you don't want me to kill Eric Voss whoa
order some g-fuel or Eric's a dead man
keep him alive yeah I didn't know he was
being held for ransom yeah this is an
adjacent Todd type scenario it is now I
think we should also thank you g fuel
thank you this actually does taste very
delicious I'll give you the taste test I
had not tried it before we did this and
I didn't make a face you saw me I was
enjoying I took another sip we gotta
thank some of our super Chatters Jose
Rodriguez gave us 20 says love you guys
we'll miss you when I'm off to boot camp
I'm hoping the language that Neymar and
his people will speak will be either
I'm guessing or one of the many Native
languages that my people that next week
Jose good luck at boot camp thank you
for your service we really appreciate
the Super Chat I uh I hope it is a great
experience for you and we are very
appreciative of you for not only super
chatting but uh for doing what you do
yeah I hope they don't speak English
just been so weird yeah I mean no
probably yeah just so that people
watching will understand or they have
like I think they could have one person
as a translator yeah like the young girl
that we saw
a word I can't believe you guys just
said that cancel Eric and Brandon yeah
it was the canceled sticker
uh Isaiah Jackson in the chat was
wondering if we think Dr Doom will make
his debut as Victor Von Doom or maybe
swipe that around Victor bondren will
make his debut as Dr Doom as a
politician from Liberia I mean
the expectations are high I think at
this point for Dr Doom in this film uh
we all know it's Everett Ross he's been
hiding in plain sight the whole time
thank you everybody knows my Ross boss
dude
straight from YouTube I mean that is a
plausible Theory this is the last film
of phase four yes come on Martin Freeman
as Dr Doom would be a curveball but
we've all questioned when Christian Bell
was cast as Batman we were like hell no
you guys were just kids because it was
2003. yeah we're barely born barely born
but I was already 33.
and we were all like no
they cut me up man it's Christian Bell
from The Machinist from Newsies from
Empire of the Sun
he's still skinny just run he's too
little
it's too Cockney right Michael came
family of one uh what good I'll just
push-ups if you can't even lift a budget
alone
he's right
uh all right now that's a different
actor are we uh I think if there is a
doctor doing this it's not to live very
very end though you know I also don't
think Neymar is our big villain in this
movie I think there is something else
they're gonna be working together to
fight pollution pollution and you're the
solution yeah stop polluting looting and
polluting is not the way here's where
Captain Planet has to say Doctor Doom
appears in the film agree or disagree
where the planet tears you can be one
too because baby in our planet is the
thing to do looting and polluting is not
the way here Captain running has the
same there's no [ __ ] way Doctor Who's
Gonna Be in this movie
Elizabeth
[Music]
the movie will end will wakanda drown
are they going to live in harmony with
the atlanteans or telecast shoes I think
it's gonna be a devil's bargain with Dr
Doom who I just said wouldn't be in the
movie he's gonna come in and be like I
can get rid of your water problem
perhaps I can send these atlanteans to
note to lotions back to their world a
little happier as well my name is Victor
Von Doom and I'm something of a
scientist myself
um uh I think we see what kind of flood
that obviously happens the waters can
thus recede I still want to know where
this water is coming from they're very
centrally located if it's a lake lake
water is different than ocean water yeah
less corrosive no salinity there yeah
yeah let's let's clip no solidity uh but
we also in the in the terms of the shots
of like uh some of the wakandan ships
airlifting stuff to the mountains yes I
think they're gonna like relocate to the
mountains maybe there's a an explosion
at the white wolf canning Factory and
that's all energy drink just flooding
towards them it's a wave of white wolf
they cut the Bucky Barnes at a bar with
his Japanese girlfriend he gets a phone
call he's like my what the factory the
white one
in Nigeria next week for big class
before they ban us all I'm gonna have to
sell some nfts oh my Bucky Apes uh
Christmas
and rock stars uh do we think that weary
Riri maybe came from uh t'challa's
Community Outreach Center at the end of
black panther one that they were setting
this up in Oakland there of course but
in theory they could set up a couple I
would love to see that connection I
would love to see that pay off somehow
yeah uh maybe the move the film starts
for sure it closes I don't know like at
least acknowledging that part of it but
I think that's a great idea I think a
lot of people would like to see that
connection also it would be the first
time I'm just realizing that Africans
have felt the need to build good schools
in America
wow we could use the help yeah we could
honestly use the help they're hiring
anyone these days our school system's a
mess do something you know our
government needs to step up and fund
education it's true my friend loose Jeff
just got hired as a math I love loose
jobs she's got his pants don't fit you
keep going I don't know you crowned them
King this is your fault Elizabeth C Ash
new rock stars and this is a big one
will our boy Bucky have a cameo in this
film
stunned silence on the panel probably
not I don't know do you see a need for
other than his connection to the level
first you don't think he's visited Zima
is someone gonna get Zemo out of jail
before it floods that's my question
right that's right Z was being held
there because at the end of Falcon and
Winter Soldiers female kind of turns
himself in agrees to go with IO back to
wakanda to face his crimes but he could
be visiting his girl I know I don't know
it seemed like they had a little thing
going uh he's saving himself for Sam's
sister he's got time you know he can
play the field what's he gonna sit
around doing nothing he's not a virgin
he lost his virginity to IO from the
door
with that good new arm Bucky Barnes went
into World War II with a few notches on
the bed post don't worry about that no
he was doing all right he was doing all
right I don't look at me keep going
and make eye contact and don't drop it
no way
I would like to see him in this but I
don't know I was you know I was trying
to think where all the the pieces were
at the end of Falcon Winter Soldiers
back in the US he's fine but like he
still has that what kind of an arm yeah
which I still don't trust at all I I
kind of would like it's just gonna freak
out well I kind of like this movie to
end a little bit with like we're kind of
being like no we're done with the rest
of the world we don't trust you guys
anymore like we opened up but I I don't
trust you guys that's a good point uh
Stacy C says and she would they I don't
know if Stacy if male female or other I
will be shocked if Bucky is not at the
funeral I wonder if that funeral gonna
be a bit like Tony Starks where it's
going to be a who's who of Cameo I don't
think they're invited are they gonna
pull like a hologram track could be like
people yeah I don't know but I mean it's
like
I I mean I know that the Tony Stark one
was he was like the I mean Captain
America's the First Avenger but he was
the first one invited into the Avengers
Initiative right so it's kind of like he
was a connective tissue between
everything and I think yeah it'll just
be well condens and people who have a
strong connection so if we do see Bucky
probably it'll be it just at the funeral
yeah well it could be like a newsreel
thing like the world borns kind of stuff
and the festivities festivities we're
seeing in the film in this trailer could
be the like okay we have the the world
tour this is like for the people back
home yeah right we're bringing it home
you know one of those kind of things I
don't I don't know it would be
interesting I would hope everyone cares
and I'm sure they will address that uh
in some some manner
um
some other super chats we got uh Jesse
Walter or Waller asking are hoping for a
killmonger resurrection love you guys
happy Monday Jesse also wondered why no
mandatory fun today this whole episode
has been mandatory fun yeah we had a
mandatory fun plan but we've had so much
discussion you guys we wanted to
participate and in true uh mandatory fun
fashion I have made the whole show about
myself anyways we'll give them one give
them one graphic all right hit the
graphic one
yeah it is this whole episode has been
mandatory fun the segment that sweeps
the world where each week every day I
invite
three of my best friends three of my my
three best friends and uh have them
participate in a little non-optional fun
with me uh is the lighting like so much
different for you when it's me sitting
there that could be right yeah I think
so I think it's made for darker skin on
the side that's okay I'll just go to a
tanning
I mean Etc on this side because you're
my black king okay this lighting is Fit
For A King uh yeah this is the segment
that is brought to you so please play
that image of imbaku
oh and to find it there come on the
break room Winston yeah if you went to
Brighton High School all right now uh
mandatory fun is over let's go back that
clap ass cat clap had asked do you think
RDJ will make an appearance in Black
Panther too uh I don't think so at all
no unless it's a flashback which I don't
think we'd get it would be I mean that
would be interesting if there was some
scene that they had deleted and saved
away in the archives that they could
bring out it'd be interesting yeah I
don't think we're gonna see RDJ for a
very long time and with killmonger uh I
don't think they would have a resurrect
killmonger but I love the idea of a
killmonger from the Multiverse coming
through but I don't think that's this
movie yeah I feel like I think they'll
save that for a later day do you think
they're saving some stuff for like also
what if I was just about to say they can
throw literally anything yeah this whole
month you know we're in the Multiverse
Saga I think I've said this before I
think Secret Wars ends the Multiverse
Saga by getting rid of a lot of
Multiverse says much like they did in
the comics with Secret Wars and what we
end up with there could be a killmonger
that is now black panther something like
that from a different dimension or a
different Universe I don't know lots of
possibilities glad it's not my decision
to make to get all these angry comments
from the universe someone said Danny
DeVito is Dr Doom can you do that
impression for us I just banged Sue
storms like wolf Cola Charlie put my
metal mask on my face is a mess of
breaking out I can't stop banging
ultrons
they do whatever you say
okay all right Christian upward outside
and uh uh Super Chat and I don't know
what this means s-u and TMS yeah suck
under no I don't know what you mean I
thought you knew what it meant but he
also said it was super Trent said what
is that
I don't I'm like a cow I got seven
stones
[Laughter]
it also said shury's Facebook almost
exactly matched the ones on the mask I
have to double check I don't know uh
send that to Eric Foster he could put it
in the breakdown yes
saying I like my trash bags broken and
roomy motivate me baby and full of trash
juice full of trash we can take care we
can take you out of the motivation
uh Ezra Wallace okay here's something
interesting what if tolokin has a
version of the hardship herb or
something sure he can synthesize because
isn't vibrating supposedly in both
places in the comics there are multiple
versions of vibranium uh throughout the
world that have like different
properties and there is some down in
Atlantis uh I love the idea that like
yeah this meteorite hits boom most of
the vibranium was there but like when it
hits it could shoot some up into the
atmosphere and lands other places like
Antarctica or whatever or it hit so hard
we saw how deep they're mining does that
like seep into the Earth and like come
up also on the other side like maybe
while they're mining they start hitting
the bottom of uh to lotion or something
like that he's like get out of here so
they can mine it too yeah I also like
the idea that like they have their own
vibranium you know what kind of opens up
to the world and Neymar's like yo
guys you can't do that like we got our
own Supply you can't be running the
market here like we want it on this
business uh we need a little we've got
everything down here underwater except
for capitalism can't wait to get our
hands on it no we hear great things it
does great things for the surface world
uh user code 10-7 I don't know if that
was a bad copy paste or if that's your
name if it is uh assimilate they said I
think the Black Panther we saw in the
trailer was actually Megan the stallion
uh from She-Hulk listen I saw that that
film and I've looked up a few pictures
of Megan the stallion that's not her
butt not not thick enough no no when she
hit the ground the whole Earth would
have it's funny because music code 1087
used to be the phone number for my
friend
loose Josh senior he uh he has loose
pants as well you'd call use a code 10-7
you get him you get Marty mcfry not
Monty McFly you get Tristan Bale you'd
get uh Stephanie D'Angelo you get
Brandon Barrick you get uh you get
everybody with that number that's just
the way phones used to work that's how
fun just to work Jessica Clemens used to
have to write a piece of written mail to
you put it in the mailbox three months
later she'd get it oh she writes you
back and she put a little lipstick on
the paper oh this is because it takes me
forever to text people back
yeah that's right that's an indictment
of your real life technological uh Bucky
Barnes uh representing the trash cans in
the chat also we just get the Super Chat
oh I missed that uh find a brand name uh
from Joe Wills art saying and the comics
Tony is an AI for Riri maybe he does
voice over work for it that must be
interesting I could see our DJ returning
as a voiceover as her Jarvis yeah as her
kind of like Jarvis or her Friday or
Edith or I don't know I don't want that
that'd be two that would be some wild
stuff I mean it's kind of like when you
go to Avengers campus at Disneyland and
like the Iron Man there sounds like
Robert dangerous it was not quite there
could work and if she just kind of like
uh does that I mean they have that like
that AI technology now that people I
mean they obviously did it for James
Earl Jones at Darth Vader but even
people on the internet now make weird
videos with the AI voices and it's it's
pretty good well you got to get Robert
upy Junior Robert yeah he's the best
Robert Downey
uh and film juice
saying Tom sir where does the king keep
his armies up his sleevies oh that's
from that's that's from last week oh was
that that is from three days ago yeah
we're doing jokes
hey how do you know when a joke is a dad
joke
wow it should be apparent uh geez Louise
that was terrible it was so bad in the
offices
I need Zach here where's my other softy
boys
you know what that joke was so bad I
think it broke the show so thank you all
for joining us today on a very Black
Panther episode of the break room uh so
happy that Australia's here we're a
little more than a month out from the
film coming out super excited uh we got
lots of great stuff coming on the show
this week we'll have all the headlines
we didn't get to today we'll probably
have lots more black panther stuff to
talk about lots of other awesome stuff
uh talking dragons on the channel today
if you've been watching I'm getting to
it uh if you've been watching House of
the Dragon Eric of course has his
trailer reaction up and I'll have this
full breakdown of the trailer up
tomorrow and most importantly on the
channel today are burial and Jessica
Clemens breakdown of Hocus Pocus
uh if you stayed up late watching Hocus
Pocus one and two did a double feature
this weekend check out her breakdown
she's dead she found tons of Easter eggs
we eventually had to cut her off because
we didn't have the resources for all the
Easter eggs she found so many eggs too
many eggs too many eggs I didn't ask for
that I didn't know why we all did that
voice but it sounded great
um
uh thank you all for joining us today uh
we hope you join us here tomorrow we'll
see you all week have a great rest of
your Monday and wakanda forever
uh we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true